- What up YouTube,
this is BizDevSunday.
What you're about to
watch is a Instagram live
of us debating our 25,
50, and 100 sneakers sets.
Please watch below and if you
are in the market fro
25, 50, or 100 sneakers,
please email me right here,
we'll make up an email,
maybe sneakerbarter@vaynermedia.com,
and email with your proposals
because we're about to drop,
this week, maybe early next week,
this whole concept of 25, 50,
and 100 pair sneaker offers.
You what up Instagram live.
We're in a meeting right now
and I decided to make
you guys a part of it.
So Andy, D Rock and Tyler and I are here,
and we are contemplating
something super cool.
When I launched my books
I launched these really cool packs
a bunch of you have taken me
up on the buy 10 sneakers,
right buy 10 of these
and you get a surprise.
And that's gonna be fresh as fuck.
Everybody who took care of
that om Facebook two days ago,
you guys are gonna love it.
Jim Quick what's up man?
Jim thank you so much,
that last post,
by the way that why I've only
got 2,000 of you real quick,
that last post,
the post I have right now on Instagram
is the most emotional
post I've ever put out
in the history of my life period.
It is a woman coming up to me
telling me that my content
stopped her from suicide
and so super heavy as you can imagine.
On a far less serious note,
before I go into my next meeting
which is now running 36 minutes late
so I'm gonna shit on those clowns.
Parin she didn't need the certificate
because it was her gun license,
I actually have it here.
Give me D Rock.
I have it on my wall.
What's that?
It's got what it means on the back.
Jesus Christ, any way this is her.
Actually the front I can show.
I don't wanna,
maybe I don't wanna show the plate.
I don't know, none the less.
Heres a (laughing).
She doesn't need because
she doesn't wanna have a gun anymore
because she doesn't want to take her life.
It was super heavy, anyway.
I wanna lighten up the
mood here for a minute
and go a little bit more on
the entrepreneurial side.
When I launch my books
I always do these packs
where if you buy 10 books
or 25 books or 50 books
or 100 books you get X.
So, we're sitting here contemplating
one of these really cool
push for the second week
for the sneaker right?
And we wanna do a 25, 50, 100 pack,
so we're kind of deciding, like,
You know, what that's gonna be, right?
What's that gonna be?
And I wanna get your guys thoughts
so if you wanna DM me or Tweet,
actually Tweet,
by the way,
if you're not following me on Twitter
you're making a huge mistake.
It is 100% where I'm mostly,
I've engaged on Twitter
every day of my life
for the last decade,
11 years, like, I'm so cozy with it,
it's so much easier.
And the comment section
here's pretty fresh
but, like, oh I don't need
to clean my camera lens,
it's just the lighting, see, see.
So it wasn't the lens,
it was just the lighting.
So anyway the reality
is that we're putting together the packs
and I thought it would be super duper cool
if you guys gave recommendations
on what I should fill the packs with.
So, like, in essence you get 25 pairs,
that's 2,500 bucks, 5,000, and 10,000.
Which of the packages should it be?
'Cause I'm gonna launch a site in a week
where if you buy 25 pairs
you send in the receipt
and you get X.
And unlike the stuff I've
been doing on social media
where it's just random,
what up Malik Jefferson?
Malik Jefferson man, a dog.
Loved him coming out of school.
Malik knows what I think about his game.
I wanted hm to be a bigger sport guy
and I wanted him to be a New York Jet.
I got neither but that's all right.
Malik, wishing you health,
health, health baby.
Do your thing.
Anyway, would love
ideas from the community
on 25, 50, and 100 sneaker orders.
What would you want in return?
What's difference about
these landing pages,
when I do what is do,
is you know what you get.
So the key is, it's 2,500,
5000, and 10,000 dollars.
I don't play around,
100 for a pair of sneakers blows me away.
I don't expect anybody to buy anything,
zero, you know just
keeping watching content
and live yours.
But I'm hustling,
I'm trying to win and I'm
trying to do cool stuff.
So for example, I think,
let's just brain storm it
right here with these people.
Like, clouds and dirt set.
- Jeff.
- We have a clouds and dirt gift now?
That's what's up, really?
- Yeah.
- [Man] The M ones, it's kind of cool.
- Down with the M one?
- [D Rock] Yeah they work, too.
- I like that.
- [D Rock] I didn't
really read that, the M-E.
They're on it though.
- [Tyler] So we're brainstorming.
- All right brainstorming.
I think, if you think about it,
heres what I love about 25, 50, and 100,
I think the 100 should be like,
a 10, we got to figure out like,
what do we save with my time?
Like 100,000 or 50, like,
100, if I travel it's 150.
- Correct.
- But what about, like,
is it 50 an hour that we
planned under the impression of?
- More or less.
- Yeah.
- I think if somebody buys,
so you know who will buy a
fuck load of a hundred pairs?
Companies.
- Yeah exactly.
- And then I can come
in and give maybe a 15.
- There's a time where you can
just scale with the people,
- The problem is fuckin'
it's only 10,000 bucks.
Like what am I gonna do,
buy 100 pairs and then
I'll come and Skype your
company for a minute?
(laughs)
People would be like, fuck you dick.
What?
- You can have people come in.
- Oh, people can come here.
- Yeah.
- [D Rock] You can do more D's.
- 4D's is $10,000.
Oh and sneakers are 10,000?
So you get 100, I, you know what?
I'll probably do a trade for the 4D's.
Like one day only.
- Yeah.
- Like a one day only.
Let's do a separate campaign
that we do on first in line
and email announce it ahead of time.
All of you have been wanting to buy 4D's
we're gonna do a one day
where if you buy 100 pairs,
which is 10,000 bucks,
you get a 4D's for free
so that's what you get with
20,000 bucks for 10,000 bucks.
- Yeah.
- Boom, okay that's definitely in.
- [D Rock] Buy 100 pairs get 4D's.
- Yep.
But on a separate landing page
at Sam's building right now
you buy 50, 100, companies will buy 100.
They'll give it to employees
and entrepreneurial organizations.
Would I give a 10 minute,
we can also sell them out.
We can maximize it, you know,
okay, if I give a 10 minute
talk, or a 15 Q and A,
'cause 15 minutes feels like the minimum.
Otherwise you're a dick, right?
- [Tyler] Yeah, and you're gonna,
- And I'll never do 10
minutes or I'll feel bad.
Alright, 15 minutes,
- [D Rock] Yep
- 10,000 so it's 40,000
it's not a good deal
but a thousand, I guess
I could do 10 of those.
Actually, let's look at here.
Yo, can somebody read the comments?
Can you go on desktop live?
No desktop live yet?
You Instagram you need a desktop live.
Alright, what are people sayin'?
This so smart because you can either,
my lame dairy, she nailed it,
people are smart.
- [Tyler] You could do
five minute podcast.
- Here's the thing.
If you're fuckin' smart you
can beat the fuck out of this
because you can go on Ebay
and do 79.99 buy it now.
And basically only pay 2,000 bucks.
- And then make them the 4D's.
- This is why I don't believe anyone.
(laughs)
Conversations.
Guys, I just felt really,
you know what, I should
level up my game from daily v
to live streaming 24/7 like old Justin TV.
- [D Rock] You can do it.
- Live V.
People have gotten really smart
from Daily V and made money.
If I fuckin' went Live V,
people would be trillionaires
out of this mother fucker.
Do they know I'm available?
I'm 44 minutes.
Alright, what's goin' on here?
That's not maymar on the wall man
that's the fuckin' real
GOAT, pay lay baby.
Pay lay.
Palle.
- [Tyler] They are now
officially ready for you.
- Alright, tell Mikey five minutes now.
And blame their fuckin' mouth.
Ethan Bradbury waddup.
Please check out my latest
post everybody who's positive
and excited out there you
absolutely need to keep spreading
positivity.
The world needs us.
The world needs you.
Please give it, please give it.
Alright, what is goin' on.
Did they laugh?
- [D Rock] Yeah, I told them you politely
asked for five more minutes.
- Do they know that I meant fuck them?
- [D Rock] Yes.
- While recommendations
hit me up on twitter
for 25, 50, and 100 pairs sneaker combos.
We're launching the website,
- Soon, whenever we have the duos.
- Sam's ready?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Cool.
Yo, what do you guys think actually?
Waddup, waddup, what do
you guys think with 25, 50,
and a hundos, like what
should I be thinking about?
What are good packages?
Go ahead, talk.
I definitely think skyping in live,
like no question, if you're an incubator,
or if you're like a private
equity firm you got your,
anything that's an organization
that has underneath them
will do it.
That's always been the
case with the books.
- [D Rock] Yes.
- [Tyler] We're not able to
pitch here for 5,000 pairs.
- I don't wanna do able to pitch me
and here's why, people are gonna feel like
I don't wanna fell obligated.
Like people are gonna feel,
it's gonna be a lose lose situation right?
They're gonna buy 500 pairs, right?
And their gonna think
like he's definitely gonna
invest and then 99.9% of
the time I'm gonna be like,
you're a startup's a piece of dog shit.
And then they're gonna
be like Gary V duped me.
All he cares about is sneakers.
And I'm gonna be like, no bro,
you're fuckin' app sucks dick.
So that's not gonna work.
I want something tangible.
But my time is the most valuable.
- [D Rock] There are experience tickets.
- Tickets to all of our events?
- [D Rock] Yeah.
- Wait 'til they hear
about the one in Miami.
The next one, the next sneaker,
I wanna do a Willie Wonka.
I wanna do one gold
sneaker and whoever gets it
gets to have dinner with like
me, Nipsi, Hussle, The Rock,
like I need to change something, you know?
- [Tyler] You could do,
something around just seeing us.
I know other people have
these videographers.
They can come in and just,
spend the day with the team.
- 25 for signed sneakers.
One person's like, can you sign all 25.
They will make money flipping 'em.
What about if you buy 50
pairs you get to come in here
and sit with me while I sign all 50 pairs
and we can talk about whatever.
It will only take me what, I
only sign one at the events.
But like I would sign both.
How long would it take me?
- [D Rock] It would take
you 50 pairs to sign all 50,
you're talkin' about 15,
you could sign four in a minute.
So it's a 15 minute thing.
- It's a fifteen minute thing.
- [D Rock] Especially
with the conversation.
It's a 15 minute thing.
- I mean you'd also have
to pay for your flight here
but you might be near, let's
see what people are sayin'.
50 pairs though is a lot of bread.
100% Eric, the fuck you think
we're doing here with you.
I'm trying to help, you
know, like it's $5,000.
It's like I'm trying to fuckin' figure out
how to bring people real value.
- [Tyler] Signing one
of these would be dope.
- Like I basically want one of
the things to feel for free.
That's always why these things
have worked with my books.
Like somebody's like, yo I
paid $5,000 to like high five.
Like if Randy Macho Man
Savage was still alive,
I'd pay 50,000 bucks to
hang with him for 15.
You know?
So then I'd be like yo, all
these Randy Savage sneakers
are free and I'll flip 'em, you know?
I'll tell you what, the 50
sneakers, and I sign them
and you can't be a dick.
Once I'm done you gotta
leave my office kind of thing
is a real home run 'cause
you're gonna sell 'em
for a buck 50 a pop.
They're signed.
Yeah, you get, I mean, we
get 40,000 emails a day.
Can I have time with you, no, to 40,000.
So you gotta,
Oh, a Q and A session
in the ask Gary V show.
You know what we should do?
25, 50, 100 and then we
should have like five
random things that are like 1,000
which is what, 10,000 bucks?
100,000 that's 100,000.
I mean the emails I get, yo
like I'll give you 100,000
so I can have dinner with you.
It's like real.
- [Tyler] And I love the guy
like the 45 pairs for you playing
him on his channel on twitter.
- Yeah that's gonna be smart.
He's gonna blow me out in Fifa.
I don't play Fifa.
- [Tyler] It's gonna be great content
and we're gonna put it on TV.
- Let's see if anybody's
got any good over on there.
How about a production,
one pair for,
Q and A session, if we each
get 50 pairs of sneakers
and a deal on 4D's.
4D's, I'm definitely gonna do that.
My guy, lil prince, we're gonna
do a one day buy 100 pairs,
which is 10,000 bucks.
And you get a 4D for free
which means you get 20,000 for 10,000.
We're definitely gonna do that.
- [Tyler] Instagram
live jump in with them.
Five minutes.
- What's that?
- [Tyler] Where'd we put five minutes at?
- 50 pairs of sneakers and
a day spent filming you.
That's interesting.
You know what we need to do?
We need to do something that's called,
after the 100 pairs we
should do one on one pairs
where you fill in the blank.
Nah, didn't work last time
'cause everybody's like not smart.
They're like, no, become
my brother for 101 pairs
or like I get a job.
- [D Rock] Give me $100,000.
- Give me $100,000 if I buy 100 pairs.
- [Tyler] Jab jab jab if
you wanted to use Nate
on a gold seaman.
- I need 50 pairs every month.
Can you do that?
I can definitely do that.
Buy 10 and rap live on
Instagram with Gary V.
It's gonna be 25, 50, and 100 because 10's
we're gonna do on social media.
Let me buy 200 pairs.
Let's go Si Bueno.
Come see me.
Anybody who's in for 25, 50,
or 100 pairs you can email me
at gary@VaynerMedia.com with
anything that's logical.
I'll do 50 pairs for 15
minutes plus my twitter handle.
50 pairs for 15 minutes.
What are we doin' for 15 minutes?
50 pairs and he wants me to
shout out his twitter handle?
Ah, you know what?
People are really,
in my opinion for
everybody who's watching,
people are not smart about
how valuable a shout out is.
- [Tyler] That's why,
- Yeah, but no not that,
well actually it is valuable.
It's a cosign, you can do so much with it.
You know what would be fresh?
50 pairs, I sign, you get to hang with me
and I tweet out like
yo, at Charles face 47
thanks for coming through
and we take a picture with the 50 things.
They get a couple
hundred twitter followers
they can take it and sue
it as an Instagram ad.
I just don't, you know what?
Can you get the whole team
organized Monday and have me
sign 50 pairs while I talk
to Andy about business?
I wanna time it.
- [Tyler] That's easy.
- Time is too valuable.
I can't fuck around.
Right?
Alright let's see what else we got
and then I gotta go to a meeting.
Young baby T.
- [D Rock] Do 100 pairs.
- 100 pairs is $10,000.
- [D Rock] Come in, share
a bottle of water with you.
- No.
Maybe the 100 pairs should be
the fucking 15 minute thing.
It's fucking worth it.
You get to talk to me
while I sign them all
and you get a tweet?
That's fucking worth it.
- [Alex] They wouldn't go like
two or three new 90 pairs.
- I don't wanna do that.
I wanna get our fucking stream launch.
I don't have time.
- [D Rock] 100 pairs is,
- No that's going to be a 104 D's.
The people that we're
gonna email everybody.
We're gonna text everybody and
tell them it's gonna go live
at nine o'clock somewhere and
whoever gets them gets them,
like because it's too valuable.
You get a 4D's which is worth
10 g's everybody's buying them
and making money and you get 20 g's
and these people are smart.
They're literally gonna
take those 100 pairs
and flip them somewhere
and get 50 to 70 K back.
I mean,
- [D Rock] You sold out
the mail times right?
- Oh shit, male 10s are finished.
- [Tyler] That's what I was thinking too.
Like the sizing might be a little weird.
- No but these people are not buying,
they only need one pair for themselves.
They're gonna be flippin' and flippin'.
But 15 minutes now make it 20.
My God, I'm trying to make it 10.
By the way, anybody here who
wants 15 minutes of my time,
which goes for a lot of money.
If you buy 100 pairs on
kswiss.com right now and
mail me a receipt you're locked in.
I'll see you in New York asap.
Do you have a vid on flipping?
There's a couple.
Lindsay Rona who I love with all my heart.
See you, my co.
4D's search it.
Vayner Media 4Ds.
Google it.
I love when people are on chat
and they're like what's this?
Just Google it.
Google.
Young baby T.
Follow her.
I pinned her for a reason.
What's up wano 73, jilani,
one minute is all I need
Nick Wall.
He only needs a minute.
Could do 25 pairs, 25 pairs is 2,500.
We could do 25 pair five
minute speed dating day.
Or just,
you know what we could do?
I got it, I got it, I got it.
We could do 25 pairs, you
get five minutes with me.
Five minutes, there's a buzzer,
there's a whole thing, right?
You can like pitch me,
we can take a photo,
but you also get to hang.
We'll do it 7 p.m. we'll go
into three in the morning if I have to.
You get to hang right here
with us, twitch studio going,
music going, I'll get
three or four influencers,
it's 25 pairs to be apart of the party.
To be the, that's it.
We'll get food, we'll give them a gift bag
that'll fucking rock their face off.
We'll get someone to addition.
Twitch studio's going, you
can put your twitch thing on,
I'll bring one or two twitch monsters.
- [Tyler] Sounds like a 50 pair thing.
- Let's give a, no, 100
pairs should be the 15,
25 let's do a party.
- [Tyler] 25?
- It's 2,500, it's a good deal.
- [Tyler] It's a really good deal.
- Like you have it for four hours,
network, like if you're
a smart business woman
you know that your coming, cool.
You get five minutes of
leverage to selfie with me,
and you guys know if five
minutes I could change
your whole fucking game.
You go play twitch and meet other people.
There will be four to five
other Instagram celebrities
or whatever we can even
put people in each room
and to little, and you know what else?
- [D Rock] Honestly, we're gonna,
- You're right.
It probably is a $5,000 ticket.
What?
- [D Rock] We're gonna have some
of your homies come through.
- Like a rapper?
- [D Rock] I don't know.
- An athlete?
You could probably put
a fucking influencer
or business, like something in
each fucking conference room.
- [Alex] We can recreate last night here.
- That's a good idea.
Let's see if they like it.
What do you guys think about that?
Somebody says it sounds dope.
I wonder if they have speed dating.
What's up.
- [D Rock] I gotta go.
- I don't have to do anything.
Guys, real quick.
If you wanna make 2,500
bucks to get the 25 pairs
go to craigslist free right now.
Pick up shit, flip it
on Facebook marketplace.
The number one way to make
2,500 bucks in a heartbeat.
It's hard work but it's a heart beat
is to go to fucking craigslist right now,
go to the for sale, click,
in the for sale section
there's a section called free, click,
look at all the stuff, see
what people are giving away,
bicycles, cabinets, televisions,
get your fucking truck,
get your car, get your bicycle,
I don't know how you role,
go pick it up, post it
on Facebook marketplace,
Facebook marketplace, and
make fucking 40 bucks here,
60 bucks here, 80 bucks
here, 60 bucks here,
40 bucks here and then in
30 days you have 2,500.
- [Tyler] I'll buy 25 pairs right now.
- Yep it's a big idea.
- [Tyler] 100 pairs to come
to the event would be awesome.
- Yeah it's a good idea right?
Okay so that's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna definitely,
definitely, definitely, do
the speed dating, we're gonna
call it the fucking party.
The 25 pair party.
Or the 50 pair party.
It's probably 50.
It costs us money.
Yeah, okay.
So the 50 pair party, you
come from 7 p.m. to midnight,
five hours, you know, you can't come early
because the fucking building will freak
so you have to like meet down
stairs, we'll figure that out,
you come up, I meet
everybody for five minutes.
You can pith me, you can photo,
I can take a picture with
your fucking product, yay, right?
Maybe we do a couple of like
4D consulting like D Rock
he doesn't need to have fun
let him look at D rock video obsession.
Like people can come in he's just talking.
We got twitch going.
We bring fucking DJ clue in here.
I'm comin' Alex.
They fucked up.
- [Tyler] Do we cap it?
- Yeah we cap it.
Of course we cap it.
First of all we don't need
to sell that many pairs.
We're doing this more for like brand.
50 pairs times 50 people?
2,500 pairs?
It's cool.
Seems like a lot for 2,500 pairs.
Should it be 100 bucks?
I feel like it should be 100 pairs.
(laughs)
Alright guys,
thank you so much for hanging us with our
25, 50, and 100 sneaker idea.
Straight up, if you
wanna buy 25, 50, and 100
pairs of the sneakers right
now and you've been listening
and kinda understand where we're at
you can email me right
now, Tyler will jump in,
we'll close that deal and for some reason
if you buy 50 because you
wanna come to the party
and we make it 25 we'll refund you back.
I'm not gonna fuck anyone.
I'm gonna make it better for you.
You're gonna be the
first people in the line
so if you wanna step up.
I wanna dismantle
kswiss's website right now
with like 50 people.
September 24th's gonna be the date?
Alright, September 24th, lock it in.
Just block it right now.
September 24th is gonna be the date.
See ya.